♪
>> Jesse: AMERICA HITTING A
SINGLE DAY HIGH FOR ANY
CORONAVIRUS CASES.
TEXAS, FLORIDA AND CALIFORNIA
AMONG THE STATES WITH THE
BIGGEST SPIKES.
NEW YORK’S GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO
THINKS NOW IS THE PERFECT TIME
TO PLAY POLITICS AND ATTACK RED
STATES DESPITE HIS OWN FAILURES
STOPPING THE VIRUS.
>> I SAY TO THEM ALL, LOOK AT
THE NUMBERS.
YOU PLAY POLITICS WITH THIS
VIRUS AND YOU LOST.
NOW YOU SEE 27 STATES WITH THE
NUMBERS GOING UP.
YOU CAN SEE THE DEATH
PROJECTIONS GOING UP.
YOU CAN SEE THE ECONOMY GOING
DOWN.
IT WAS NEVER POLITICS.
IT’S SCIENCE.
THEY’RE IN DENIAL.
DENIAL IS NOT A LIFE STRATEGY.
>> Jesse: GREG, LET’S NOT PLAY
POLITICS.
I’M GOING TO PLAY POLITICS AND
BLAME EVERYBODY ELSE EXCEPT
MYSELF, RIGHT?
>> Greg: YEAH, I MEAN, I THINK
THEY HAVE TO GET OVER THIS TIT
FOR TAT THING.
FRANKLY EVERYBODY AT ONE POINT
DURING THIS WHOLE THING WAS
WRONG, INCLUDEING THE EXPERTS.
NEW YORK RANKS 48 OUT OF 50 IN
SURVIVAL RATE?
HE SHOULD BE MORE HUMBLE AFTER
THE NURSING HOME THINGS.
WE ALL MADE MISTAKES.
WE HAVE TO BE OPTIMISTIC AND
LOOK AT THE DEATH COUNT.
THE DEATH COUNT IS LIKE -- IN
THE UNITED STATES OVERALL IS
DOWN 80%.
YOU CAN FACT CHECK ME.
I’M SURE.
BUT WE KNEW CASES WOULD RISE AS
YOUNG PEOPLE STARTED GOING OUT
AGAIN AND SUMMER, INTERACTION.
PEOPLE STILL HAVE TO BE SAFE.
YOU HAVE TO WEAR YOUR MASKS,
TAKE THE PRECAUTIONS WITH
DISTANCE AND DO THAT.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT -- I’M
TURNING MYSELF INTO A SLIM
GORGEOUS STIMULUS PACKAGE.
I NEED TO GO OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY AND SPEND THE MONEY I
HAVEN’T SPENT AND GET THE
ECONOMY BACK ON ITS FEET.
I’LL BE WEARING A MASK, BE SIX
FEET AWAY BUT I’M GOING OUT
THERE.
IT’S TIME.
WE ALL HAVE TO BE STIMULUS
PACKAGES.
I HAPPEN TO BE A SEXY ONE.
>> Jesse: GREG GUTFELD, THE SEXY
STIMULUS PACKAGE.
ALL RIGHT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT CUOMO
PATTING HIMSELF ON THE BACK?
THEY HAD A TOUGH TIME IN
NEW YORK.
I DON’T KNOW IF NOW IS THE TIME
FOR CONGRATULATIONS?
>> Dana: WELL, YOU KNOW, IF
YOU’RE SURROUNDED BY A MEDIA
THAT TELLS YOU THAT YOU’RE SO
AWESOME, MAYBE YOU’RE GOING TO
BELIEVE IT.
THE OTHER DAY I WATCHED CBS
SUNDAY MORNING, A SHOW THAT I
LIVE, I LOVED IT MY WHOLE LIFE.
I WATCHED THE INTERVIEW THAT
JANE PAULEY DID WITH THE
GOVERNOR.
SHE NEVER ASKED HIM ABOUT THE
NURSING HOME POLICY.
IT’S ALL ABOUT HE’S THIS AMAZING
BACHELOR AND A MANSION.
MAYBE GREG COULD DO ANOTHER
MONOLOGUE ABOUT THE MEDIA.
IT’S UNBELIEVABLE.
I WILL SAY THIS.
I HAD THE MAYOR OF MIAMI ON "THE
DAILY BRIEFING" YESTERDAY.
HE SAID HE UNDERSTANDS GOVERNOR
CUOMO’S POSITION ABOUT HAVING
PEOPLE FROM FLORIDA QUARANTINED.
HE SAID IT WON’T QUIBBLE WITH
THAT.
THEY REALLY WANT TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND MAKE SURE PEOPLE ARE
SAFE.
THERE’S SOME PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT
PLAYING POLITICS.
>> Jesse: JUAN WILLIAMS,
OBVIOUSLY AS GREG MENTIONED AT
THE TOP, THERE’S MORE CASES.
WE WERE TOLD TO EXPECT MORE
CASES AS WE FLATTEN THE CURVE.
DO YOU SEE IN YOUR OPINION A
SECOND WAVE ON THE HORIZON
POTENTIALLY OR DO YOU SEE THIS
AS JUST WHAT WE HEARD WAS GOING
TO HAPPEN?
>> Juan: I THINK YOU TOLD ME YOU
DON’T BELIEVE IN THE SECOND
WAVE, RIGHT, JESSE?
SO I DON’T --
>> Jesse: I SAID I WASN’T
PREDICTING A SECOND WAVE.
>> Juan: RIGHT.
SO I JUST LISTEN TO FAUCI, TO
THE CDC DIRECTOR.
THEY SAY WE’RE STILL IN THE
FIRST WAVE.
YOU KNOW, THE SURPRISE TO ME IS
THAT I THOUGHT A LOT OF THIS
WOULD DIE DOWN DURING THE SUMMER
MONTHS.
IN ANY CASE WITH REGARD TO
CUOMO, HE’S NOT SO MUCH AS
PLAYING POLITICS AS THE TABLES
HAVE TURNED.
USED TO BE THAT NEW YORK WAS IN
DIRE SHAPE AND NOW THE BIG
SPIKES ARE ELSEWHERE, ESPECIALLY
IN THE SOUTH AND THE SOUTHWEST.
YOU KNOW, HE’S JUST SAYING TO
THEM, YOU KNOW, THOSE PEOPLE
WERE TELLING NEW YORKERS THAT
THEY COULDN’T COME TO THEIR
STATE AND NOW THE TABLES HAVE
TURNED AND CUOMO WANTS TO
PROTECT NEW YORKERS FROM
EXPERIENCING ANOTHER WAVE OF
THIS VIRUS.
I ADD THAT SENATOR CORNYN OF
TEXAS IS NOT URGING PRESIDENT
TRUMP TO WITHDRAW MONEY FOR
TESTING BECAUSE HE SEES WHAT’S
GOING ON IN TEXAS.
>> Jesse: YEAH, THE DIFFERENCE
IS YOU’RE NOT SEEING A SPIKE IN
DEATHS IN THE OTHER STATES LIKE
YOU SAW THE SPIKE IN DEATHS IN
NEW YORK STATE.
ALL RIGHT.
DAGEN McDOWELL?
>> Dagen: BEFORE BRAGGING,
TAKING RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
THOUSANDS THAT DIED IN NURSING
HOMES BECAUSE OF YOUR EXECUTIVE
ORDER.
FLORIDA HAD 5,000 FEWER DEATHS
IN NURSING HOMES BECAUSE THEY
BANNED COVID POSITIVE PATIENTS
FROM GOING TO SAID NURSING
HOMES.
I WATCHED THE CUOMO BRO SHOW
LAST NIGHT.
THE GOVERNOR SAID THERE’S NO
DOUBT THAT WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DO IT BETTER NEXT TIME.
TALKING ABOUT THE NURSING HOMES.
OH, NOT KILLING PEOPLE?
BY DECREE FROM THE GOVERNOR’S
MANSION?
I WOULD USE THE WORD ASS HAT
HERE BUT THAT WOULD BE AN INSULT
TO HATS.
ACTION AND YOU’LL ASSES.
>> Jesse: I FEEL LIKE I’M ON THE